el maestro de deportes de la escuela les
pregunto a los estudiantes cuánto tiempo
se tardan en caminar a la escuela aquí
está la gráfica de lo que respondieron
estos son los minutos que se tardan
caminando a la escuela y estos son los
alumnos por ejemplo eduardo tarda 21
minutos
carolina tarda 35 minutos bianca tarda
28 rematadas 7 minutos y matheus tarda
21 minutos veamos qué es lo que nos
preguntan cuáles de los siguientes
estudiantes se tardan más de 14 minutos
en caminar a la escuela elige todas las
opciones correctas veamos la gráfica nos
preguntan los estudiantes que tardan más
de 14 minutos en caminar a la escuela
aquí está la línea de los 14 minutos y
vemos que de todos los estudiantes sólo
está emma tiene un tiempo menor a los 14
minutos
todos los demás tienen un tiempo mayor
ya que sus barras están por encima de la
línea de los 14 minutos así que todos -
emma tarden más de 14 minutos en llegar
a la escuela
elegimos a todos menos a amd y vamos a
comprobar nuestra respuesta es correcta
veamos otro problema 5 estudiantes en el
club de acertijos de la escuela tuvieron
un concurso a ver quién podía encontrar
más palabras en una sopa de letras
tenemos que aquí fein yang encontró 25
palabras ya sea min encontró 40 luck
encontró 45.000 encontró 30 y daniel
también encontró 30 veamos qué es lo que
nos preguntan cuál de los siguientes
estudiantes se encontró más de 20
palabras en su sopa de letras
vamos a ver nos preguntan quién contó
más de 20 palabras
esta es la línea de las 20 palabras y
que creen todas las barras de cada
estudiante terminen bastante por encima
de esta línea de las 20 palabras así que
vamos a seleccionar a todos todos
contaron más de 20 palabras
shenyang yasemin look min y daniel y
vamos a comprobar la respuesta
comprobamos si es correcta vamos a
realizar otro problema más
el consejero de nutrición de la escuela
le pregunto a los alumnos cuántas
calorías hay en los bocadillos que comen
aquí veamos la gráfica que nos dan las
calorías en el bocadillo y lo que dice
cada uno de los alumnos que tiene de
calorías los bocadillos que comen
entonces nos preguntan cuáles de las
siguientes personas comieron bocadillos
con menos de 350 calorías veamos la
marca de los 350 está aquí todo lo que
esté por encima de esta barra tiene más
de 350 calorías y lo que esté por debajo
de ella tiene menos de 350 calorías así
que de esta marca sólo un haba y denis
tienen bocadillos con menos de 350
calorías no haba y denis vamos a
indicarlo aquí
un haba y denis y vamos a ver nuestro
resultado es correcto